quand j'ai parlé au maire dans les 500
communes où il y a eu ce ces émeutes
d'abord elles sont intervenues fin
juin c'était beaucoup de très jeunes qui
étaient dans les rues et c'était des
jeunes c'est une erreur qu'on a
commise qui était souvent sans école
depuis le mois
d'avril réforme du brevet réforme du
baccalauréat l'organisation commune le
système tel qui marche plus de classe
loisiveté les vieux parfois disent
beaucoup c'était des jeunes qui ont pas
la chance d'avoir des familles qui les
emmènent à la mer à la montagne qui
justement ont pas assez accès à la
culture au
sport il s'ennuyent il y a eu un
événement déclencheur la mort d'un jeune
je ne parlerai pas de ce qui est en
cours et dans c'était dans le casre
d'une opération policière on s'en
souvient tous du jeunes Noë et l'enquête
est en cours donc je ne veux pas en dire
plus là-dessus mais ça a été l'élément
déclencheur mais il y avait
ça des jeunes sans activité très jeune
et ensuite les écrans ont eu un rôle
très important qu'on avait jamais vu
c'est-à-dire en quelques minutes on
voyait des centaines d'actions se
déployaient des rendez-vous donnés sur
tel ou tel je ferai pas de
stigmatisation réseau social par l'écran
et il y a eu une forme de mimétisme qui
a conduit à un embrasement totalement
déraisonné et ça a été une forme d'émeut
totalement nouvelle qu'on a vécu des
jeunes très jeunes qui allaient pas à
l'école qui étaient tous derrière leurs
écrans qui utilisaient les écrans pour
se rassembler et qui en quelque sorte se
lancit des défis par écran et qui était
cette génération un peu que j'évoquéis
tout à l'heure donc vous voyez bien que
la réponse
elle peut pas être univoque c'est pour
ça que j'ai pas voulu céder à
l'injonction du moment est-ce que la
réponse c'est l'immigration c'est la la
lutte contre l'immigration non il faut
lui apporter mais c'est pas une réponse
aux émeutes est-ce que la réponse
c'était plus de policier non on a recréé
on avait recréé déjà les dans ces ville
elles avaient toutes plus de policiers
que 2 ans avant toutes est-ce que la
réponse cétait plus d'investissement
politique de la ville ce que me disait
disait de l'autre côté c'est pas vrai on
avait plus de programmees de l'Agence
nationale de rénovation urbaine dans
toutes ces villes il y a jamais eu
autant de Gru dans ces villes jamais
j'ai plus que doublé le budget de
l'enrue durant le premier mandat il est
passé de 5 à 12 milliards d'engagement
donc les réponses faciles de gauche et
de droite classique que j'ai vu selon
les orientations des après tout faux
réponse plus compliqué et donc la
réponse c'est de se dire un on doit
réengager avec les familles c'est ce que
je disais je v pas ici rentrer dans le
détail être trop long accompagner
familles pour les aider ce qu'on a
commencé avec les les 1000 premiers
jours mais on a besoin d'accompagner
certaines familles 60 % de ces jeunes
venaient de famille
monoparental ça c'est un continent caché
on a commencé à répondre dans le premier
quinena avec les aides parce que
beaucoup de ces mamans seul 95 % sont
des mamans souvent on leur payit pas la
pension on a apporté des réponses par
nos réformes mais on voit bien
quand une famille parental élève un
jeune deux jeunes trois adolescents
c'est très dur et donc on doit les aider
et les responsabiliser ensuite on a un
sujet sur l'accompagnement des jeunes
qui commencent à
décrocher avoir une réponse plus adaptée
dans le système scolaire mais aussi
avoir une réponse je dirais prépénal
puis pénal qui est plus clair ça fait
partie des choses qu'on est en train de
préparer on a l'accès au sport et à la
culture essentiel pour ces jeunes on a
réorganisé déjà ça c'est une réponse à
ces émeutes le temps scolaire ils iront
tous jusqu'en juillet il y aura plus de
temps scolaire qui est perdu en mai et
en juin et ça c'est essentiel de le
tenir les écrans la réponse arrive et
donc c'est un ensemble c'est un problème
beaucoup plus compliqué dans ce contexte
là oui le service national universel
fait partie de la réforme c'est pourquoi
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir dans les
prochaines semaines mais nous irons vers
la généralisation du service national
universel en
seconde il est cohérent avec ce que je
viens de vous
décrire